Hello Everyone!
新米料理人の．．．
ハァッ．．．
てんてんてんてんてれんてんてれん
てんてんてんてんて・・・
ムッシュ・ハジメだ(｀･ω･´)
まぁじでそろそろ本格的に自炊をしようと思います
というわけで今回は
アァッ///x２
パチン
私はじめしゃちょー基本的に料理がなにもできないんですけども
まぁちょっと今後の健康面を考えたりしても、やっぱり料理をしていかなきゃいけないんですよ！
なんか料理のアニメなんですけどそれを見てからすげー料理がしたくなったわけなんで
今日は男の料理していこうと思うZE☆
とりあえずまずはできそうなことからやっていこうと思います
ではいこう！！
今回何を作ろうかといいますと
こちらのね。
こちらの様々の本を参考にして作っていきたいと思います
今回は！
を、作っていきたいと思います
材料はこちら
パチン
まな板がなかったんで買いました
ガチでやってくかんね？今後は
行くZE☆
食材じゃなくね？（笑）
ご飯はまぁ許してください
あ、待ってどうやってチンすんの？
電子レンジないじゃん．．．
捨てちゃった電子レンジ．．．
\いつ？/
\湯煎できるじゃん！ほら！ボイルできる/
あ、おっけおっけよかったよかった
後は色々調味料です
さっそくこの具材を使って作っていきましょう
\玉ねぎ玉ねぎ・・・/
まずは温泉卵を作んなきゃいけないんで卵をケトルにブチ込みます
じゃあ卵二つ這い出しまーす
次が玉ねぎ！
包丁今まで家になかったんですけど買いましたよ
ほらぁ．．．
友人）あぶなっ！
こうでしょ？
皮むくよー
完成しました
玉ねぎ完成しました（してません）
玉ねぎ切ってきます
まず半分
おっけ
玉ねぎ切れました
フライパン使っていくよ？
フライパンの上で色々します
ごま油入れていきます
で、広げていきます
あぁ！怖い怖い！やばいやばい！
もう始まってる！始まってる
あぁもうこれいつまで出てくんの？ホントに:(
あつぁ！！！！！！熱い！！！！
はいっ↑！！
待って待ってホントやばい
あ、水が入ってたのね
ねぇ、無理ィ(´;ω;｀)もぉ
ね、ほらっ！
ほらっ！
PPPじゃないよ！
あっ、ア”ァ”！
豆板醤、入れます。
あぁ！もうだめだ終わったわ
終わった終わったこれ
ねぇねぇねぇねぇ
へっへｗ
ねぇ！もう完全に・・・
ア”ァ”！
やばやばい待って無理無理無理マジ無理マジ無理マジ無理マジ無理
あっ//熱い！
ほんとに熱いって！
ねぇ(´;ω;｀)
ねぇほんとにヤバいほんとにヤバい
水のせいだよね？これ\うん/
にんにくいれます
にんにく・・・
ああぁあぁぁあぁ！
これをちょっと混ぜて言います
ああああああああづい！！
あづい！！！
うん、いい香りしてきましたでもぉ
で、なんか匂いが出てきたら
次は肉をいれます
肉行きます
ほいさっ
よーしよしよし
炒めますわ
こーやってじゃあ色が変わってきたら
たまねぎを入れます
ジュージュージュー
ヒョイっ
ジュージュー
\ジャンプしてるだけじゃん/
もうそろそろかなあ
はい
お肉の色が変わってきたので
たまねぎを入れます
たまねぎいくよぉ('ω')ノ
たまねぎ\わーい/
ラストスパートや
これまとめて炒める感じで
いいんじゃないっすか
さぁみんなもうすぐだＺＥ☆
次はこちらぁ
すき焼きのたれを少しだけいれます
おっと
おっけおっけ！
ご飯の盛る方は、完成でございます
ひとまずちょっと
卵の様子を見てみよう
おぉ
ぅわぁ
あつ、あーうー怖い！
どうすりゃあええんや
あー、あぁん♡
むりぃ(´;ω;｀)
水をなくせばいいんだ(^-^)
水を出しちゃいましょう
卵だけぽいぽいっておき・・・
あぁっちゃ！
おっけー卵出せました
あつ！あぁっちゃ！あつ！
あっ、手で持てねぇわケトル
卵はこれで準備完了です
あとはもう簡単です
ご飯の上に
この肉をこーやって乗せて
その上に卵とねぎを乗せたら
（パチン）
完成です
よいしゃぁ×１
よいしゃぁ×２
やぁ！
ええんちゃいますか？
\きたねぇｗ/
たまも・・・
あっつあっあっ、
やばいやばいやばいやばい（！？）
ケトル・・・だよ？
温度、ケトルだよ
真ん中に卵割ります
（コンコン）
（むきぃ）
（むきむき）
え？×１
え？×２
え？×３
え？×４
（むきぃ）
はいっ！
はっはｗ
え、これほんとはさぁ
あれでしょ？
トロってなるんでしょ？
割ったらさすがになるでしょ
（ぱか）
はっはははｗｗ
ゆですぎましたね(・∀・)
おーけー！完成でぇす！
やぁー、まぁ、全体的には良かったんですけども
やはり、卵ですね
まぁ・・・
ゆでてしまいましたね(・ω・)
トロっ、じゅわぁって行く予定だったんですけども
ちょっときれいに
ちょっときれいにゆでちゃって
まぁそこはでも問題なく食べれるのではないかなと思います
ではさっそく食べてみましょう
いただきマックスむらい！！！(｀・ω・´)
味だよ味、いただきます
（ぱく）
（もぐもぐ）
（ごっくん）
うまい・・・！
うまい！ぞぉ！？
うわぁすげぇ(´;ω;｀)
俺今日コンビニ行かなくていいんだ
夜ごはん食べにぃ
すごい(´;ω;｀)
というわけでとてもおいしいんですけども
僕だけ食べててもやっぱわかんないと思うんで
最後にちょっと試食してもらいましょう
どう？
おいしい♡（！？！？！？！？）